hi everyone
um good afternoon
um I am priyana tarajan
um I'm the current director of the
Frankie program in science and the
humanities
and I'm delighted to invite you all
today for our colloquium uh
understanding the nature of inference uh
this has been a series as you all know
that we have had since the past year
and I may I want to start this afternoon
by first
um thanking and recognizing uh the
generosity of Mr and Mrs Richard and
Barbara Frankie
and um who have funded the Frankie
program and many other interdisciplinary
activities at Yale
uh I want to remind the audience that
because this event is being recorded all
videos and microphones will be muted and
as per custom we request you to submit
questions in the Q a feature of the
webinar
as you all know the inference uh
understanding the inference nature of
inference series colloquium series is
one in which we have been looking deeply
at the process of inference across
disciplines with a real view to
understand
the utility of conceptual models
simulations arguments
um that are particular to a discipline
but transcend and teach us something
more profound about the notion of
causation inference and cause and effect
as well as correlation as you know we've
assembled a core group of experts across
intellectual disciplines ranging from
epidemiology cosmology genetics
organizational behavior climate modeling
and to today's speaker uh philosophy
uh today speaker I am absolutely
delighted to um introduce him uh
Professor Alex pizo
who is
um a professor of philosophy at Oxford
and it is a particular pleasure for me
because he is also a very good friend
and so inference
is a logical philosophical term that
Professor pazo will show us has been
used to describe the process of deriving
conclusions from premises
and the conclusion drawn from the
premises is what we refer to as
inference in this talk he will explore
the mathematical and philosophical
aspects of Interest
and the word infer means to deduce or
draw a conclusion from the evidence
that's provided and it's the process of
using logic to come up with a conclusion
there are two types of inferences
deductive and non-deductive inferences
so he will be delving into the two kinds
of inferences and showing us the domain
of validity of these two forms of
inference
and in particular he is going to be
um showing us that mathematics has a
very long tradition of using formal
reasoning
but some mathematicians have argued that
there's a need for non-deductive
reasoning in the field
so mathematics has always been
considered an exact science but in the
last century it is seen as more of an
art with many different multiple
approaches for problems so in today's
talk Professor pazu will present some of
his ideas about non-deductive reasoning
in mathematics and explain why contrary
to popular belief it can be actually a
source of knowledge as well as Justified
belief but before I turn over the floor
to him let me give you a formal
introduction
um Alexander pizo read mathematics
follow followed by a year of philosophy
part two at Trinity College Cambridge
and after taking his b full and
philosophy at Oxford he returned to
Cambridge for his PhD he spent 2001 as a
visiting graduate student at Princeton
after three years of a research
fellowship at Jesus College Cambridge he
moved to Oxford in 2005 where he's now a
professor and a fellow of bottom College
he has been an associate editor of the
journal mind and has held research
fellowships from the Mind Association
and the Lee William Trust as well as
visiting appointments at the Sydney
center for the foundations of science
Kings College London and The Institute
this story the philosophy The Sciences
and techniques in Paris
so um as uh as is usual we will have the
colloquium today and tomorrow we will
continue with a conversation with
Professor Cher of the University of
California San Diego who will be talking
to Alex and interacting with all of you
in the audience tomorrow at the same
time
but uh before
um I um
turn it over to um Alex I just want to
quickly uh mention that uh we have a
virtual talk this is upcoming uh Frank
events we have a virtual talk by the
journalist Esther honig
um on Wednesday November 16th and we
have an in-person talk by the architect
uh and NASA engineer James Ramsey on
November 10th
and we will have our next nature of
inference colloquium talk uh given by
the computer scientist Brian Cantwell
Smith
so without further Ado Alex the floor is
yours and we are absolutely delighted to
have you speak here today
thank you very much Priya for that warm
welcome I'm extremely pleased to be here
and to be able to discuss with you and
share with a broader broader audience uh
some ideas it's been 20 years since we
were part of a discussion group just out
of grad school and it's very nice to
sort of repeat that
I I'd also like to thank the funders too
so my topic today is inference from a
logical and philosophical perspective I
work primarily in the philosophy of
mathematics and logic so that is
effectively my perspective that I'll be
um
describing
and I'll introduce the topic give you
some references and then focus on two
topics first the idea that logic is
infinite and secondly on non-deductive
inference reasoning in mathematics and
maybe speculate at the end on the link
between the two
um so let's begin by distinguishing as
prio already did
um just to follow up on that between
logical and non-logical inference
so
um what is the difference between the
two well let's have an example the first
inference that I want to mention is the
following all horses are ungulets all
ungulates are mammals so all horses are
mammals
okay now you I hope will recognize this
to be a formal a valid inference
that is to say the conclusion follows
from the premises if the premises are
true then the conclusion also has to be
true and the interesting thing about
this inference is it's it instantiates a
formal pattern a formal schema all laser
B's all B's are C's so all A's are C's
and you can see that any instance of
that is valid
and in fact in order to recognize the
validity of the argument you don't have
to know what any of the adjectives there
me or any of the words like predic
horses and ungulates and mammals mean I
try this out regularly on my first year
students I ask them I show them this
argument and I ask them whether the
premises make the conclusion true or if
the premises are true does that mean
that the conclusion has to be true and
they all recognize that the argument is
valid they all recognize that the truth
of the premises necessitates the truth
of the conclusion even though and then
I've asked them the follow-up question
even though most of them do not know
what the word angular means that just
highlights I think the fact that we can
recognize them at this argument to be
valid just in virtue of the form
whatever the word angular means
the counterparts are logical inference
is non-logical inference so just to give
us a simple example of this previous
samples have boiled at 100 degrees
Celsius so this one also will
so that's non-logical the conclusion
does not follow from the premise the
single premise there necessarily
and it's not formal the um if you
schematize it if you turn it into formal
that says they you say previous A's have
been a B's so the next a will be a b you
can see that that's that can be a good
inference in some cases but will not
um invariably be a good inference for
example if you've rolled
um a die a couple of times and it's been
a six both times then to infer that it
will be a sixth the next time you throw
it is has a one in six chance of being
true so certainly not a a valid argument
okay so that's the difference between
logical and non-logical inference how
would we characterize logical inference
many would Define it as follows the
necessary truth preservation in virtue
of form the conclusion
um file is necessarily from the premises
in Virtual form as in the ungulates
argument
and a mathematical proof and I'm going
to focus on mathematics later so it's a
particular interest to me a mathematical
proof is a logically valid argument from
some axioms and this is a fact that's
come to be appreciated in the past 100
120 years
um or so that's to say the you can turn
any mathematical argument into a logical
argument from the axioms of that
particular area of mathematics or
perhaps more broadly or the actions of
all of mathematics
and reasoning in science and everyday
life and also in mathematics has both
logical and non-logical aspects
sometimes we don't notice it in everyday
life but we do use logically valid
arguments and but we also often argue in
a non-logical way
however mathematics is somewhat
exceptional
in that there a claim is regarded as
established only if it has been proved
it's only a result if it's been proved
in other spheres of
um of intellectual activity in other
walks of life you can establish a result
a claim without proving it in a strict
sense but in mathematics a claim is only
regarded as as really established if
it's improved it becomes a theorem
so
the um I wanted to so I want to talk
about both forms of validity and
my claim about logic and and stake out
two claims
um one one per form of validity the
claim about logical validity
um that I want to
examine is where the logic is finite
okay and this is actually a sort of a
tenet of contemporary thought or to put
it sort of pejoratively a Dogma and I
will argue instead that uh logical
validity uh can be infinite what it
means for logic to be finite or infinite
I will clarify shortly
um the other sort of tenet about
non-logical is about non-logical
validity is in mathematics at least that
this is sort of second rate
um the best form of argument is as I
mentioned logical or deductive you might
say but and in mathematics anything that
doesn't meet that standard in some sense
doesn't cut the mustard and so in
particular a non-logical inference
cannot provide knowledge of a
mathematical play
okay so those are the two top um the two
Theses I'm going to talk about and try
to argue against giving some reasons uh
for My Views
I'm going to give you some references
here on the on the logical validity side
of things
um this idea that logic is infinite that
I'll be
um describing and defending
there are some Pioneers in the field who
um on Whose work I'm building uh the
first is Alfred tasking
um who in a 1966 lecture that was
possible posthumously published in 1986
uh first developed that the idea that
logic is infinite um but broadly
speaking and then there's Gila share who
I'm very pleased is with us today and
who will be my discussion tomorrow and
in her work building on task key
um she uh has also developed this idea
ranging from an early book The bounds of
logic in 91. so her most recent book
very recent in fact
um logical uh consequence and my
contribution to this
um debate this domain has been in most
recently in the monograph one true logic
co-written with Owen Griffith which came
out a few months ago that's on The
Logical validity side and then the sort
of references uh on the if you want to
do some further reading on the Less on
the non-logical reasoning side of things
as a classic mid-20th Century Classics
classic by George polia called
mathematics and plausible reasoning and
that was came out in the 50s and 60s
more recent and more philosophical
engagement has been by Don Fallas
in a couple of Articles and I've also
cited one of mine from 2015. okay so
those are the references if anyone wants
to do some follow-up reading so let's
move to the first big idea that logic is
not as sort of current thinking has it
finite but is in fact infinite okay so
the first thing we need to get clear on
is what it means for logic to be finite
or infinite okay
so a logic is in many ways like an
ordinary language right such as pick
your favorite ordinary line natural
language ordinary language English
Arabic Spanish Mandarin
philosophers by the way as I already did
call these natural languages
in distinction to
um Logic the language the language of of
a logic contains some vocabulary and it
also contains rules for stringing
together the vocabulary we'll call that
a grammar that's true of a natural
language that's just English as well
so two let's give two examples of
grammatical rules uh for English
so if a and b are sentences then they're
conjunction A and B is a sentence
so for example if Fido is a dog is a
sentence and Felix is a cat is a
sentence then so is the sentence spider
is a dog and Felix is a cat that's
called the destruction
and if a and b are sentences then so is
that disjunction that's when you join
them together by the word or
and to say that logic is fine I just put
it very roughly is to say that all the
sentences are a finite length
but in contrast an infinite logic allows
you to conjoin join with and or dis join
join with all infinitely many sentences
and to quantify over infinitely many
variables so you can say there exists
not just one One X but exists X there
exists y begs is z but you can quantify
over infinitely many variables
okay so and I'll explain that a bit more
as we go along infinite Logics have been
a minor area of mathematical study since
the 1950s but they're not generally
regarded as correct as capturing um
correct
form of implication the usual term here
by the way in the field is finer tree
versus infinitry but for the purposes of
this talk
um I'm going to just use the simpler
finite and infinite
so
um the argument for the infinitive logic
is to my mind made up of two sorts of
considerations
there's what I call the bottom-up
arguments and these
are rest on relatively light theoretical
principles you don't need a great deal
of theory or theoretical commitments to
accept bees they sort of rest on things
that most people believe about logic
already
or slight extensions of of them
the top-down arguments are much more
theoretical they're based on the nature
of logic and or The Logical constants
what are The Logical constants that
won't be that relevant today but
um they are just to clarify that their
expressions such as and or there exists
and those are dealt with the two sorts
of arguments I discussed in respective
chapters of my recent monograph
okay so let's look at an argument
um though let's consider this following
argument
it consists of the premise there's at
least one planet a second premise
there's at least there are at least two
planets third premise there are at least
three planets and so on for all finite
numbers
so it has infinitely many premises and
then it has a conclusion and that's
drawn below
um the line the conclusion is there are
infinitely many planets okay so if we
think about that argument
this argument seems valid
um in some sense that's to say the
conclu the premises necessitate the
conclusion okay if the premises or put
it another way of the premises are true
the conclusion must be true because if
there's at least one planet at least two
at least three at least four and so on
then there's got to be infinitely many
okay and the question is whether it's
logically valid
um or not okay so my claim which I will
not be able to defend him and I'll just
state is that this argument is in fact
logically valid one can show that it's
logically valid or what can argue that
it is
the second claim is that standard logic
which is finite cannot capture it
okay and this is actually quite an easy
claim uh to establish that the standard
logic which is first order logic cannot
capture this this argument as logically
valid
because briefly
um if in first order logic and standard
logic if there are if there's an
argument with infinitely many premises
and a conclusion it's a valid argument
there's also got to be a sub-argument
made up of finitely many of those
premises that entails the conclusion and
clearly if you just have finite me many
of those premises you know that there
are say two planets at least two planets
at least 53 at least 412 up to some
finite number then it doesn't follow
that there are infinitely many
the third claim is that other finite
Logics cannot capture this argument's
generalizations
and the fourth claim is that an infinite
logic can
so this is a this is what I call a
bottom-up argument right you in order to
capture the validity of this argument
assuming it is logically valid and
that's claim one you need effectively
what the what the argument is
um is that you need a infinite uh logic
a finite logic isn't going to cut it
it's not going to be able to capture the
validity of this argument
let me give another example
of a
um another another consideration on the
sort of bottom-up side
consider this argument here and and the
reason I want to give another argument
is to make it look a little bit less
mathematical less to do with numbers
Bob is not my parent Bob is not my
grandparent Bob is not my
great-grandparent and so on okay you
keep on iterating the grades therefore
Bob is not my ancestor
now this argument is not formally valid
if you change the word parent in all the
premises so in in the word in the first
premise turn it into say child uh turn
the word parent
in the second premise the child to make
a grandchild and so on then it the the
conclusion will not follow so it's not a
formally valid argument it's not just
valid in Virtual form
but I if we add the meaning premise
um we can make the argument formally
valid and the meaning premise here is
the premise about the meaning of the
word ancestor and what's the relevant
idea well you're my ancestor if you are
my parent or grandparent or great
grandparent or so on okay so this is a
this is a list that continues adding fan
item
and if we add that uh premise then the
argument becomes formally valid and can
be captured in an infinite logic
so just to give you a sense of what an
infinite logic looks like the sentences
of independent logic look like
um the formalization of this Bob
argument plus the meaning premise would
look like this the first the first
premise would get formalized as not p1b
that's to be understood that as Bob is
not my parent right so then the first
the first symbol there is a not sign P1
means is my parent and B uh it can be
understood as Bob
not Bob the second premise Bob is not my
great grandparent and so on and the
meaning premise which we've added is
that for all x x is an ancestor
if and only if that double arrow can be
read as if if and only if
um
some that thing that X is either my
parent or my grandparent or my
great-grandparent and so on and notice
that that big V sign it's a big
disjunction is infinite right you need
to disjoint infinitely many
um formulas there so that's the sense in
which that formula that that uh that
logic is infinite and from that the
conclusion follows that Bob is not my
ancestor
okay so so that was the so that's the um
these These are the sorts of uh
bottom-up arguments that one can develop
um to uh further to argue that logic
should be infinite
another sort of bottom-up argument it
consists of a sort of uh Alex I have a
quick question yeah so that's um so that
rests on the fact that you have an
infinite layered set of relationships
right
you have an infinite premise premise set
correct right okay
yeah
actually that's very relevant to
something that I'll mention in in a
couple in a few slides thank you Priya
um so the the thought experiment
um imagines the following sort of being
a superhuman who can accomplish super
tasks those are infinite these are
infinite tasks that can be completed in
a finite amount of time okay so a
superhuman
um is capable of uttering an infinitely
long sentence such as the following zero
is even and two is even and four is even
and and so on so for every even number
that uh that that claim that that number
is even gets included in the sentence
how does a superhuman do it well they
utter zero is even in one second then
they speed up they say and two is even
in half a second they say N4 is even in
a quarter of a second and so on so that
after two seconds they've uttered an
infinitely long sentence okay now
superhumans uh we do not think exist
um they're not biologically possible
perhaps
um they perhaps they're physically
possible perhaps they're not the
important Point here is that they're
certainly conceptually possible
um there's nothing sort of conceptually
wrong with assuming that they could
exist um even if they don't actually
exist
so suppose that superhumans perform the
following sort of inference they say
they utter this infinitely long premise
and then they utter another uh
infinitely long sentence again using
speed up but this one's a little
different they say zero is even and four
is even and eight is even and so on
so what they do in uttering the
conclusion is they drop every other uh
clause in the uh premise they drop the
two is even clause and six is even close
and ten is even and so on and they just
say the multiples of four
okay so I think so this looks very much
like
um a sort of inference that logicians
think is completely fine in the finite
case you know if you have a and b and
from that you infer that a
um clearly that's completely fine and
that's valid um but in this case there's
a Twist because we have an infinitely
long uh premise and an infinitely long
conclusion
so it's an infinite form of what
logicians call conjunction elimination
you you you have a conjunction and you
eliminate some of the contacts and this
looks just as valid as a finite form of
conjunction elimination okay
um and you might say in response to this
well this inference is something that we
can describe in finite terms I've just
done this and giving you the slide and
talking about it but actually we've got
to imagine the superhumans actually
carrying out
um the inference okay we can come back
to that in the questions if you like but
that's the sort of uh that's the sort of
thought experiment that is supposed to
make more Vivid the idea that if logic
if finite logic is a standard finite
logic is logic then why not go
um further and think that an infinite
logic is also logic okay
okay so there are more bottom-up
arguments than the above uh but it's
time I think for a sort of important
clarification and here I must
um confess to something I have to fess
up to something I labeled my uh talk
inference a logical philosophical
perspective but actually in this part of
the talk I'm talking about implication
rather than inference strictly speaking
and what is the difference implication
is really a relation between sentences
okay something that holds from between
some premises and a conclusion or
premise set if you like and a conclusion
and it's a fact that holds between
sentences and it's not anthropocentric
so in the angular argument whether the
premises entail the conclusion is not
something that we do it's just a fact
about those sentences inference on the
other hand is something that an agent
performs
and it is an anthropocentric notion
because an an agent Reasons from
premises to a conclusion
even if we consider idealized agents
that still a sort of anthropocentric uh
notion okay even for example if we think
about Bayesian epistemology about
Bayesian reasoners who are idealized in
in some sense in some ways
that still is a form of inference and
logic's main role um is I think I
believe to capture implication it
captures the relations between sentences
how does it relate to inference well the
study of inference and rationality is
informed by Logic but it doesn't boil
down to logic
so let me give you an example of what I
mean by that so suppose you you believe
a some fact a and you and you and you
ask yourself what else should I think if
I believe a
well then you might re you might come to
appreciate the fact that a logically
implies B right this is a fact about
sentences that a implies B
but whether you then go on to believe be
um isn't it determined entirely by the
fact that a logically implies B you may
think that b you may find be very
implausible you may think hang on
I believe they I now realize that a
implies B but B is very implausible so
maybe I should have another think about
a maybe I should not believe a okay so
there may be all sorts of rational ways
to uh to react to implication facts and
implication facts aren't going to
determine
um all inferential facts so implication
is uh captures facts about sentences and
inferences uh facts about what reasoners
do
okay so having said that
um we can ask what language applied
logicians or logicians who think about
uh using logic to capture
these things as in the uh to capture
um
arguments couched in language such as
the angular argument or the planet's
argument or the Bob argument um I gave
earlier what language are we actually
interested in here so I've given these
arguments in English
um but actually the choice of a
particular language such as English for
example a natural language even if you
understand a language to include all the
technical vocabulary right so when I say
English the examples I've given so far
have mostly been sort of homely bits of
um vocabulary you know about planets
about about horses and mammals uh about
Bob being my ancestor or not that sort
of thing but you can throw in all the
sort of technical vocabulary of the
Sciences of mathematics of the law and
so on so on but the choice of any such
language would be uh as as the sort of
focus this Central focus of a logician's
study would be somewhat parochial
why is that well because natural
languages sort of grow they accrue words
by the day that just to take an example
I can't play my DVD on my laptop well
that would have been incomprehensible to
victorians okay so it would be quite odd
to give an account of
logical implication that just applied to
English as it is today on the 28th of
September 2022.
that would seem too parochial too narrow
a project you want to you you really
should the logician should really be
interested not in any particular natural
language including the technical Parts
as it is today when it's in its
extensions uh as well
and once we appreciate this fact that
opens the door to generalizations of the
bottom-up arguments that go beyond the
count of the infinite assets that go
beyond
um the Infinity of the natural numbers
zero one two three and so on
okay so that's so much for the bottom-up
arguments so that they strongly point to
the conclusion that logic cannot be
finite but must be infinite now let's
move on to the
um other other type of argument for the
Infinity of logic and this is a top-down
argument about the nature of logic so
what is the nature of logic well two
features of logic that are generally
accepted are generality and topic
neutrality generality is the idea that
logic applies to all spheres and topic
neutrality are very closely related idea
is that it doesn't have a topic of its
own but rather it applies to all all
areas so for example mathematics is
about numbers and functions and
um shapes in geometry and physics might
study particles economics rational
economic behavior be it of idealized
Agents or actual economies and so on
these all have topics but logic is topic
neutral is the idea
and the electrician that I mentioned
earlier famous 20th century logistian
tasky he made this idea of topic
neutrality precise by considering
permutations
so if you look consider the set ABC and
a permutation mapping A to B B to C and
C to a
think of that permutation it's just
shuffling the elements around or some
sets such as the set ABC is mapped to
Itself by this permutation okay some
sets are mapped to themselves by the
permutation they're invariant under it
because a gets mapped to B B to C C to a
but others are not for example a b is
mapped to the the others are distinct
set B and C because a gets mapped to B
and C B to C so it's variant under the
permutation
and if you think of properties and
relations as a sets and Define what it
is for a property or relation to be
permutation and variant then you can get
a notion applying to these of variants
applying to these properties or
relations so for example the property
being American and the property being
self-identical if you think about all
the um all the eight billion almost 8
billion people on the planet uh today a
small subset of those are American so if
you permute the uh the eight billion
people
um on the planet today and you map some
Americans to some non-americans then the
property the set of the Americans uh
changes
um however the property being
self-identical is a property that's had
by absolutely everyone on the planet
okay so however you permute the people
on the planet a set of people on the
planet
um that property is not going to change
it's going to be the set of all people
okay so that's that and that that aligns
with sort of intuitive judgments that
being American is not a logical property
but being self-identical is a logical
property
uh now
um there's a there's a complication here
because being human for example on the
domain of all people alive today as I
said the almost 8 billion people well
that will be permutation variant as well
because however you permute them they're
all human so the set of uh human beings
over this uh is going to stay uh fixed
over the uh world's population
um but like being American being human
is not topic neutral so Gila share had
the idea
um the uh correct idea that's a removal
sensitivity to subject matter we must
consider not just permutations of a
domain but by injections to others of
the same size as to say you map them to
other sets of the same size so you've
got you've got the almost eight billion
people
um the demand of all of of the uh in
Hamilton inhabitants of the planet today
you can map those almost 8 billion
people to say the natural numbers and
then being human is not preserved on the
back on the mapping and the technical
name for this which I will not use but
won't you want to say nonetheless is
isomorphism invariables
and the theorem proved by Van McGee
links this notion of invariance to the
Infinity of logic so roughly a property
or relation of the right type is
invariant just when it's expressible by
a formula of and this is how this is
pronounced L infinity infinity and this
logic L infinity infinity is in a sense
as infinite as can be
highly highly infinite logic
so more technical explanation it would
be to say that it extends standard logic
by allowing for any any Cardinal Kappa
it's the Greek letter Kappa conjunctions
and disjunctions of Kappa many disjuncts
conjuncts or disjuncts respectively and
allowing quantification over Kappa many
argument places
so to properly appreciate this you have
to know that there are lots of different
sizes of infinity and what this is
saying is actually for whatever size of
infinity you pick
um you the logic n infinity infinity is
as large at least as large as that
so just just to uh because this was a
somewhat more technical this last idea
the the sort of the top-down argument I
want to summarize it
how does it start it starts from the
characterization of logic as being topic
neutral
okay
and topic neutrality and this is
something that's generally agreed topic
neutrality can be more precisely
understood as the notion of invariance
that I described okay that's a more
precise
um way of spelling out and so it's a
precise way of spelling out this notion
of topic neutrality and it turns out
that this notion of invariance coincides
with what can be characterized in a
highly infinite logic
so the upshot is that we've got a
top-down argument from the Infinity of
logic if you ask what is logic
the answer is is topic neutral you spell
that out and it turns out on that basis
you get an argument that logic is not
just infinite but highly infinite
and so these two sorts of arguments
actually converge they point to the same
conclusion the top down and the
bottom-up arguments point to the
conclusion the logic is highly infinite
which in today's climate is quite a
radical thought because up till uh until
fairly recently until today it's it's
almost universally logic is almost
universally regarded as being finite
okay and yet
um I believe as I sketched that there
are good reasons to think that it's
infinite both top down about the nature
of logic and bottom up about which rest
on much less theoretical considerations
about logic
okay so that was the logic side of
things and then the last third of the
the talk will be about non-deductive
inference in mathematics and here I will
talk about uh squarely about inference
and this is the other side of the coin
the implication inference distinction
that I mentioned earlier will not be
very important here
and usually when applied to mathematics
this may be called informal or
non-deductive inference
um or reasoning so I'll I'll switch
between those ways speaking
okay so just to motivate this
let's think a little bit about this
simple example suppose let's say you're
you're a high school student and you're
sort of playing around with the odd
numbers okay and you notice a pattern
okay you notice that one well of course
that's one squared then you add one plus
three and one and three and you get four
so two squared one plus three plus five
you notice that three squared one plus
three plus five plus seven is four
squared and this is news to you you know
you're not a mathematical whiz
um you're a high school student who's
never encountered this before and so you
form the conjecture that the sum of the
first n odd numbers is N squared
and then you might test quite a few more
cases uh you might test them by hand
maybe you'll you know some coding so
you'll program a computer to test the
first billion cases
um and they all turn out to verify this
conjecture but do you know it do you
know the conjecture even if you check
the first billion cases and I think the
answers are clear no right
um you what you have is some some good
but very partial evidence and in
particular you lack of proof right until
you prove that the claim it's not very
it's a very easy claim to prove but with
assuming the high school student has not
proved it at that point when they have
improved it just notice the pattern even
for the first billion cases they do not
know that they claim they haven't they
lack of proof
foreign
okay now there are mathematically much
more interesting examples where we have
more evidence and not just a little bit
more evidence but a lot more evidence
and the example I want to give you
um is that of golbas conjecture called
it GC and it dates from 1742 in a letter
by Christian goldbach to Leonard Euler
it states that every even number greater
than 2 is the sum of two primes okay so
here's an example six is three plus
three and that's the only way you can
write 6 as the sum up two primes three
is of course Prime
or you can write a hundred or to take
100 you can write that as 97 plus three
that's one way of doing it for 100.
another way would be 53 plus 47.
and then there are lots of other ways
the interesting thing about gold bass
conjecture despite the fact that it was
that it was um conjectured almost 300
years ago
it's currently unproved
but another interesting uh fact about
global conjecture is that we have a lot
a lot of evidence for it so let me just
run through some of the evidence not all
of them this is by no means an
exhaustive list
the conjecture has been checked for
every even number up to 4 times 10 to
the 18 right so a lot more than 10
um than a billion cases
every suppression we also know we it's
also been proved that every sufficiently
large even number is the sum of two
numbers there the first is a prime
and the second number is either a prime
or the product of two primes so that's
getting very close to the conjecture and
that fact has been proved
it's also been proved and this was
actually in the 2010s that every odd
number is the sum of three Primes
again very close to the conjecture
slightly weaker clay
it's also been proved that every number
is the sum of no more than six primes
okay the gold Mass conjunction remember
says that it's it's exactly two I mean
you can do it with just two
so again this is a weaker claim but
that's also been proved
we we also know that the in for the
cases that we know about for the full
time up to the four times sense of 18
cases
um not actually all of those but quite a
lot of those number of ways that an even
number can be written as a sum of two
primes sort of non-monotonically
increases it doesn't increase in a sort
of monotonic fashion just going straight
up but you know a bit like
um a currency sort of strengthening sort
of goes up and down a little bit but
with the kind of underlying
um growing Trend
um so for example in the case of six uh
we saw that six can be written in just
one way as a sum of two primes three
plus three but a hundred can be written
which gave it at least two ways of doing
it and it can be written in quite a few
as the sum of two primes in quite a few
ways
and in fact when you get to some a
number even as small as about 10 000
that can that number can be written as
as the sum of two Prime in hundreds of
ways
which makes it very implausible that
somehow this is going to sort of Crash
from from being able to to write a
number as a sum of
um several hundred uh in several hundred
ways as a sum of two primes the next
even number somehow that's going to
crash and go down to zero it's it's a
plausibility argument it's not a proof
but um that is the thought
there's also a heuristic argument using
the prime number theorem and the prime
number theorem tells you about the
distribution of primes up to a
particular n tells you roughly how many
n numbers smaller than n are prime
and it also there's an argument based on
it that strongly supports the idea that
go Mass conjecture is true it doesn't
prove it
um it's basic it's based on how many
numbers smaller than NR Prime and if you
look at the the sums of these numbers of
these prime numbers well according to
this heuristic argument every a typical
integer that small or equal to n should
be writable as the sum of two primes and
sort of about n over 2 log N squared uh
ways so in other words that should grow
as n gets bigger and uh and bigger and
that's not a proof but it's a it's a
heuristic argument from the sort of
distribution of the primes it's also
been proved that the counter examples uh
the density 10 uh tends to zero that's
the say yeah at any given point if you
look at how many numbers
um up to that point might be counter
examples to the Golbat conjecture well
that that ratio is going to definitely
provably 10 to zero and there's a
there's more evidence for of compass
conjecture
so as I say lots of very strong evidence
for the truth of gold gold base
conjecture that does not add up to a
proof in quite varied sort of evidence
uh too proofs of closely related results
numerical evidence heuristic arguments
um and so on
and there are lots of other interesting
um conjunctions in mathematics today one
is the
probably the most famous unproved
conjecture in unproved statement in
mathematics the Riemann hypothesis you'd
have to be more of an expert on that
area of mathematics than I am to cite
the evidence uh carefully there
um and there are other sorts of
arguments uh that are non-deductive in
mathematics for another well-known one
is primality testing
for example the Robin Miller test and
this the way this test works is you
put forward a number n natural and a
whole number n and then you run a test
on it to see whether it's Prime
and you can do this
um several times and every time you do
it the result is uh the claim the
verdict of whether it's prime or not
prime is independent of the previous one
if if the number is prime and so if you
run the test a thousand times with
different inputs and a thousand times
the test the test says that n is prime
then it's provable is provably the case
that n is Prime with this probability
one a probability at least one minus a
quarter to a thousand
and that's just running the test a
thousand a thousand times of course you
can run it a lot more times and increase
the exponent there now one minus a
quarter of a thousand is extremely close
to one right it's a degree of confidence
in ends primality that that outstrips
almost everything
um any evidence that we have with
respect to anything in ordinary life uh
and also in in science so we can be
extremely extremely confident that n is
prime it's not a proof that n is prime
but it's a proof that n is Prime with
extremely extremely high probability
okay
um so by all normal and even scientific
standards the evidence for uh the
Callback conjecture is extraordinarily
strong
but most mathematicians nonetheless
would say that we don't know gold
goldback's conjecture
um even the ones who have all the
evidence that's to say number theorists
who know there's evidence about the
conjecture
so I want to suggest that actually
they're wrong about this
that in some cases and probably in the
case of gold gold bus conjecture I'm
going to stick my neck out we do know
the truth of the claim
and what is the what are the sorts of
considerations
um we can run here well in the interests
of time I'm just gonna
um State them I'm not gonna uh go into
them in any detail
the first consideration is actually that
deduction doesn't have any sort of
special
epistemological virtue so people have
thought that deduction preserves
certainty if you're certain of the
premise you should also be certain of
the conclusion so there's something
special
um in that sense about deduction but I
don't think there's good reason to I
think that
um and just to run through the second
the others can um if you if you look at
the sort of analyzes of knowledge
um in philosophy and epistemology they
allow they either allow for
non-deductive uh knowledge of
mathematics or they just do not apply to
the case of mathematics
so General General philosophers are not
particularly interested in the in the
philosophy of mathematics have come up
with conditions on knowledge
they don't seem to rule out
non-deductive knowledge of mathematics
is the argument
second consideration and the third
consideration that the axioms of the
foundation are also Justified are often
justified in terms of their consequences
so it would be a bit odd
um to justify some axioms of the
foundational mathematics which is
usually taken to be set theory in terms
of their consequences
um that are typically more like
scientific sort of evidence
non-deductive evidence but then insist
that in order to know anything in
mathematics they must be provable from
those axioms which are justified in this
sort of non-deductive way
and a fourth sort of consideration is
that there are strong links between the
mathematical and the physical you can
know applied mathematical facts by
observation and testing you know you
might be able to know what the mean of
this distribution is by by sampling uh
you might be able to
you you'd be able to
um work out some facts about geometrical
facts by uh for example doing
experiments on physical triangles
um you might know numerical facts by
looking at clusters of physical objects
and so on and in those cases I think we
clearly want to say that in the physical
case we we know those facts but then
because they sort of are analogous the
mathematical facts it'll be strange to
say that we know the physical facts they
have corresponding mathematical facts
um but yet we don't know those
corresponding mathematical facts if we
haven't proved them okay so I realized
I've run through those fairly quickly
but that's because I want to wrap up
um and
and just very briefly as my last slide
what is the link between the two things
that I've talked about okay so remember
the first my first argument was that
logic is infinite against the sort of
tenet of contemporary thought that logic
is finite and the second one was that
strictly about inference this time that
mathematical inference is not as bad as
it might seem uh and in fact can lead to
knowledge so maybe I'm not entirely sure
myself but maybe what links them is a
sort of permissiveness about inference
and about implication
and and my claims are that there's much
more to logic than recognized it's
infinite in fact even highly infinite
rather than finite and that non-logical
inference can be more reliable and is
often appreciated
um and even in mathematics where the
deductive method Reigns it should be
recognized as giving rise uh to
knowledge so thank you very much that's
it
great
thank you so much um Alex that was um
absolutely brilliant
um we can now open up the floor to
questions
are there um any questions
please go ahead and um type in your
questions
um
I just give people a couple of minutes
to
um get their bearings
so um if I may I may start so what what
is special about the structure of
mathematics
obviously this is a big question but
there is something about
um
isn't there something about the
structure of mathematics that there is
an inherent provable
self-consistency
that you can demonstrate right say
compared to say physics
yeah
okay thank you
um
I think I think what makes mathematics
special is
that it's so abstract
that it's about
um structure in general
so for example it might be
about the structure of the natural
numbers or it might be the real numbers
but those can be described in very
abstract terms and they may have
physical instantiations or not
um and that means because we can
characterize them in this very abstract
way
um then we can use abstract arguments uh
to to discuss them
and therefore makes the the sort of
deductive method possible because you're
just looking at characterizing axioms
right that's all it takes to understand
the structure
and and uh and the structure and the
sort of relationships between
um objects mathematical objects
are somehow they are more um
they are not
they cannot be perturbed by
experimentation right so the the analog
that you have in physics that you you
have a system especially you know
quantum mechanics is obviously the
dramatic case where you know the act of
making an observation Alters the system
itself right so there is something about
this stability right
of mathematical objects that permits you
to make these logical arguments or if
there's something about the fixity right
so
um
yeah absolutely so I don't I think there
isn't
any sort of Observer interference of any
kind in the mathematical case
um and I mean that's so in the physical
case as you mentioned there is that
famous instance and and of course it's a
major problem in social science
um that
our role as theorists uh social
scientists who are theorists are
involved in the actual
swirl of of human life right uh and
therefore can affect it so there isn't
that sort of feedback uh in any way and
that maybe is one reason why that makes
it sort of cleaner and easier yeah
yeah
I think uh we have a question from Peter
Morgan what is the role of the Axiom of
choice in this kind of infinite Logic
for the Superhuman example what
difference does it make if the
Superhuman misses out
a non-procedurally determined set of
multiples of two ah there's a gap right
thank you very much Peter Morgan uh
that's an excellent question
um so
so the example I gave with the
superhumans can be stated
um and fleshed out without using the
Axiom of choice
um because you can say it you can
specify the rule that I gave the
inference that I uh mentioned can be
described
quite simply you're just missing out the
multiples of
two that are not multiples of four
um so you don't need the action of
choice for that particular example
to answer the second part of your
question
um what difference would it make if a
superhuman misses out a non-procedurally
determined set of multiples of two yes
in that case in order to to imagine an
inference of that sort you might have to
invoke the acting of choice
um depending on what what is actually
emitted
um but the the idea doesn't rely on it
it does not rely on the Axiom of choice
because you can just describe it more
simply in the way that I did
so the next question is from K7 and is
the claim here that the high degree of
certainty is or perhaps should be
sufficient for mathematical knowledge
okay cassavan yes uh thank you um no my
answer to that is no
um I don't think High degree of
certainty um is enough
uh I don't think that's necessarily true
in any sphere
um it's you need varied evidence
um I I don't know how to I don't think
it's easy to describe exactly what's
required but you need more than high
degree of certainty you need varied
evidence uh so the evidence of different
if different types and evidence that
would convince uh there would you know
that many experts would think would give
you an extremely high justification so
just to give an example of why High
degree of certainty is not enough
um in general I mean you know they're
the famous Lottery cases described by
discussed by philosophers you have a
lottery ticket
uh you think you believe it's not going
to win there are maybe a million um
lottery tickets and you know you're
you're right it's not it doesn't win did
you know it well you didn't really know
it
um even if your degree of certainty was
extremely high
so I I want to say that high degree of
Sanity is very can help but but it's not
enough you need to look at the Quality
it's not just the sort of quantity if
you like the quality of the evidence but
I do think that in some cases for
example the case of the Golbat
conjecture probably we do have that
quality of evidence as well as the
quantity
that's sufficient for knowledge
thanks so the next question is from
Alexander Meehan thanks for a very clear
talk I'm curious to hear more about the
connection between logic and inference
and what the bridge principles are if
there are any for example I was
wondering if you could take your
arguments that logic is
infinitiary to show that deductive
inferences in fiduciary and related what
would it mean to say that deductive
inference is infinitiary
foreign
good I mean I think these are very
difficult questions
um
there are bridge principles and it's
actually an active area of research in
philosophy epistemology more
specifically to work out what are the
bridge principles between implications
and inference between logic and
rational inference but it's actually
quite tricky uh to spell them out
precisely
so you might think it's something like
well
um if you uh believe the premises then
you ought to believe that
um then you ought to believe the
conclusion
so it will be something along those
lines but there's sort of devil in the
detail there uh and it's it's work out
it's hard to work out precisely what it
is but it's something along those lines
um as for the second part deductive
inferences infinitry I've sort of
um did not want to go that far because
as I said deductive inference is
something agents do and I find it hard
and and yeah you know superhumans can
carry out infinitry uh reasoning but we
are normal humans uh cannot and so if
deductive inference is very much tied to
what we can do even somewhat idealized
versions of us then I'm not I don't know
if the duct of inference is infinitely I
don't want to go that far
um
yeah thank you
so the question is about the argument
from topic neutrality
I see that to be able to characterize
topic neutrality we need to make use of
higher infinities
but does this mean that our logic needs
to incorporate these infinities
and another version of the same question
maybe is topic neutrality a neutral
topic or is this special to the topic of
logic is it tied I guess to logic right
I see okay thank you Mark
um
right so
yes so to cat so it's not so much that
to characterize topic neutrality we need
to make use of higher Infinities it's
more that
when we spell out what topic neutrality
means what kind of expressions or what
kind of relations and properties are
topic neutral
they are the ex they are they are the
relations that can be expressed by an
infinitary logic so it comes by way of
Discovery we're not using the higher
Infinities they sort of come out of the
argument they tumble out of the of the
argument or another way of putting it
you just think about these infinite
conjunctions or disjunctions
um they preserve con eliminating
conjunction infinitely many conjunctions
preserves topic neutrality it's not
specific if you want a concrete example
it's not specific to any particular
domain
so that's why that's how the argument
goes from topic neutrality
infinite in and highly infinite logic uh
falls out
another version of the same question
maybe you asked is topic neutrality a
neutral topic
um or is it special to the topic of
logic okay that's a tricky one we've got
some self uh reflection going on there
um
topic neutrality
is a broad I don't I don't know how to
answer that directly but I'm not sure we
need to topic neutrality is a feature a
characteristic of logic it is special to
the topic of
um logic it doesn't apply I suppose the
answer is maybe straightforward I guess
maybe I'm now thinking I now think it
may be straightforward it is special to
the topic of logic other other topics
are are not a topic neutral you know the
law has a subject matter particle
physics as a subject matter
microeconomics as a subject matter and
so on but logic is seems like it's the
only branch that has
um that is topic um neutral
yeah so then there's a question from Joe
um you distinguished implication from
inference as apples and oranges I think
but wasn't your first thesis about the
first and your second about the second
um yes
um correct my first thesis was about
implication and my second one was about
inference they are closely relate I I
want to be clear that they are distinct
but I also want to say that they are
closely related and as I fast up
um that my I wanted to align this with
with the topic of this of this of this
series uh so I my snuck it into the
title as as imprints they are related
but but they are but nonetheless to get
to to be clear they they are distinct
things
um are there any um other questions
actually you know if you have a question
feel free to ask
and maybe I'll keep the question for
next time but maybe just one small thing
about topic neutrality
and it is very common in philosophy to
say that a a copy a logically static
neutral because it doesn't have a topic
of its own
and but I think that this is not
accurate and logic is topic neutral in a
logic does have a topic of its own and
that is logical implication on logical
inference no other discipline studies
this and logic studies this so that's
definitely a distinct topic that logic
has but at the same time what is right
about that and why it's important that
logic is static neutral is that this
topic logical inference applies to all
fields of knowledge
and so it applies to all topics it
applies to all other topics and that is
because of certain very special features
of logic that apply to our topics so for
example physics does not apply to
numbers
but logic applies both to numbers into
physical objects so that's just a small
comment yeah thanks for that uh
clarifying comment so there is one more
question from Peter Morgan so a
differential equation can be a model for
say an electrical circuit or a pendulum
is that not topic neutral
okay
um thank you Peter so
I I would say that it's not exactly
topic neutral it's very general but it's
not quite topic neutral
um to take the straightforward case uh
maybe it's over the real numbers
um and so to differentiate
um a function over the real numbers it's
got to be you know a differentiable
function so it has to have a pretty uh
specific kind of form it doesn't that
the the equation just can't apply to any
phenomenon uh whatsoever so it's very
general yes but not quite as general uh
as logic
right
so that that that that was an um
interesting question to unpack this yeah
that was absolutely yes thank you
um so we have another question from
Alexander Bean so following up on a
previous question it wasn't obvious to
me how evidence for the Goldberg
conjecture differ
s
um nature from evidence for winning a
lottery
uh I have a different intuitive reaction
but can you give me a more principled
argument it seemed to rely on diversity
of kinds of evidence
um yes okay so it's good
um so the if the evidence uh for the
okay so the
the evidence for the the diversity of
kinds of evidence is is crucial
um I think uh and that is a big
difference
um from the
um Lottery uh text and the lottery case
um and I think that's that's a principle
that we apply in all sorts of uh you
know uh spheres of reasoning right I
mean for example the you know testing
the boiling point of water I mean if you
however many times you test it if you
don't vary certain conditions right if
you don't vary the pressure or the
height or we always do it in the same
room
um then I don't think your evidence is
as good as if you did it perhaps fewer
times but across a very different range
of cons context and changing uh other
variables
um so I think it is very relevant uh to
have that you have all sorts of
different types of evidence now the
thing that I also went over rather
quickly admittedly uh towards the end of
the talk
was sort of more philosophical
considerations for how you might convert
this idea of
very strong and diverse types of
evidence into just uh an outright claim
of knowledge and and I think really the
the onus is on someone who doesn't think
this to try and defend it and the sorts
of arguments I I gave there were you
know a kind of um arguments that that
have come up in in the kind of ideas
that have come up in Philosophy for
example the nature of knowledge
um do you have one sort of analysis of
the nature of what knowledge is is a
popular one which is not exactly right
but a sort of right track is that it's a
reliable true belief okay so if you have
a true belief
um about something and it's acquired by
a reliable method then that's knowledge
now that's not quite right we know that
from Decades of epistemology but it's
along the right lines and the method for
basing your mathematical for
foreign
is I think a reliable one
um and again it's you know I think it's
important that there are these heuristic
arguments right about the nature of the
primes how many primes there are up to n
and it would just be there's no reason
and you speak to a mathematician you
know the mathematians say there'd be no
reason to expect it not to hold given
the distribution of the crimes so there
are
there are there are there are sort of
inherent reasons here that go beyond
just a lot of cases just sheer quantity
there is uh there are some follow-up uh
questions as another follow-up question
I'll draw with that
um I might have a diversity of evidence
that I won't win the lottery I've done
many lotteries before and lost there are
lots of tickets in this Lottery I'm
generally an unlucky person
etc etc and it seems that the process of
concluding based on this kind of
evidence is a reliable one
yes okay good so the the lottery cases
show that rela it can't quite be
reliability there's got to be there's
got to be more to it than than just
reliability but but but again but the
lottery cases
um they're sort of they're sort of
insensitive to
um to whether you hold the winning
ticket or not I mean you would still
even if you held the Willing ticket you
would still believe that you weren't
going to win the lottery assuming you
believed that you didn't win the lottery
just to get the structure of the counter
the alleged counter example here you're
saying well in the lottery cases uh we
don't want to say we have reliable true
belief that we're not going to win but
the thought is we don't have knowledge
and that's correct but it's also
insensitive to whether you um have
knowledge
um to whether you hold a winning ticket
or not because if you did by chance hold
the winning ticket you would still think
the same things but the mathematical
case isn't like that
um if the um if callback's conjecture
were false and that's a very hard thing
to to uh to spell out but we would
expect quite different sorts of evidence
is the idea
right so actually I want to go back to
um this point that you made about
um then you know our conception of the
nature of knowledge and how reliable
true beliefs so if you if you look at
physics right so you are inherently
knowledge is inherently provisional
so are you making a claim that
mathematical knowledge is doesn't have
that kind of provisionality
that it's reliable I mean that
reliability is uppercase are somehow
No in fact I'm I'm very I'm very drawn
to a more scientific picture of
mathematical knowledge and what in a way
that's why I'm that's part of what's in
the background here okay yeah I think
mathematics is is a bit more at least a
bit more like science Natural Science
than most people think
and of course this sort of non-deductive
reasoning is all over the place in
science right
um uh yeah and so and I think the
history of mathematics show uh shows
that mathematics I mean it's it's more
cumulative than science but it's not
entirely cumulative you know there are
revolutions in mathematics
um there are things that we believe that
everyone believe you know that all
numbers were uh positive or all numbers
were real uh for centuries or that you
know the parallel postulates or
um you know Euclid and what his common
notion says that the whole is bigger
than its parts actually set theory on
one way of understanding that this
proves that
so I I do not I I don't have that
picture of mathematics as sort of
Eternal in that in that way
yeah and that's uh okay now that kind of
fits while uh so that's why you're
making a claim so you're making the
distinct uh sort of distinguishing
between sort of deductive and the
non-deductive part of okay so you're
kind of making room for a more
provisional
um yeah okay absolutely so I want to
assume I I I'm drawn I I'm trying to
assimilate mathematics the science
because that's where I think it it is
closer to science than we think okay
in its method
um
are there any other questions
um
I'll just give another minute if anyone
has a last minute question
but um thank you so much Alex that was
fantastic and thanks for Patiently
um taking all these questions and
clarifying
um I I learned a lot and it's very
interesting to see that
um you are trying to construct a a view
of knowledge and Mathematics that
actually aligns it much better with uh
sort of knowledge creation and knowledge
in The Sciences
and I I wonder
um
you know the sort of the the next kind
of
um uh barrier right if you will or the
next threshold to cross right
so is uh you know in scientific
knowledge in physics and many other
disciplines right
um is experiential and experimental
right so there is room for sort of
empirical investigation do you see what
is the portal that is opening up in
mathematics that uh takes you
somewhere near there or is this a very
different kind of provisionality that
doesn't sort of go in that direction
yeah I mean there is a field of
mathematics which is known as
experimental
um mathematics
um and and there is there's lots of
things like probabilistic proofs
um and you know the kind of arguments
that I that I discussed
um
so
I mean it could be it could be
I mean one of the things one of the
things that you uh one of the types of
evidence that I've just described is
like induct what's known as inductive
evidence right you just have more you
have a lot of A's that are B's and you
infer that A's of B's
um so that's typical of science but you
also get another more subtle form of
argument form a more subtle a form of
argument that happens in science which
is inference of the best explanation
you've got a different phenomena
and then they you can find one
explanation that covers them and the
classic example is Newton Newton's
theory of gravity unifying Celestial and
terrestrial Mechanics for example okay
um and I I see that as also applying in
mathematics you've got disparate
phenomena in different areas of of
mathematics and then you can find a
unifying theory that makes sense sense
of them uh making sense in this way in
mathematics will usually be implying
them right right so you've got phenomena
in area a phenomenon and area B and then
you find area C that somehow encompasses
both and entails the results in area a
in an area B right but it's the same
sort of thing
I looked at through a general lens it's
it's it's a it's something that allows
you to make sense yeah when I buy your
argument uh for the purposes of thinking
about progress right so what is progress
when are you accumulating new knowledge
so um I see the the analogy that you
just gave Works aligns very well with
physics right you often say that you
know Newt uh Einstein's theory of
general relativity
reduces to the Newtonian case but it's a
more General sort of it's more sort of a
larger covering Theory right so the
explanatory domain is much larger
compared to sort of Newton's theory of
gravitation right so I see that that is
sort of what you are invoking right that
there could be larger covering
um area C could sort of cover and
Encompass
um multiple existing domains but would
you but I mean I guess the question that
begs the question right in physics that
would be progress and I mean that would
be a measure of progress and of
accumulation of new knowledge
right so does is there the same notion
of progress then built into uh the
accumulation of mathematical knowledge
I would argue that yes I mean and sure
yeah and this is one of the ways in
which you you get that progress
um takes place
um you find a larger area that
encompasses areas that you knew about
before
um I mean an example from 19th century
algebra is the development of group
Theory
uh which was you know got away in the
work of galua uh was really about
finding solutions to
um polynomial equations but then it
turned out to have all sorts of
applications outside
um that context and so it it there was a
kind of general theory that of about of
groups that could develop emerge that
that could Encompass lots of different
phenomena in mathematics not just not
just Solutions of polynomials
great um so there's one final question
before we let you go is deductive logic
non-deductive
um
I don't know how to answer that Joe I I
think I think deductive logic is
deductive logic it's it's deductive is
what I'm going to say I'm gonna just I'm
just gonna uh repeat it
okay great so if there are no further
questions uh let's all thank Alex for a
fantastic talk and a thought-provoking
talk and we look forward tomorrow to the
conversation
um between Alex and Gila thank you
everyone for coming and see you tomorrow
at the same time at 3 P.M Eastern
thank you so much Priya and thanks to
everyone for their questions yeah thank
you